>>> I WON.
THANKS FOR TEACHING ME HOW TO
PLAY CARDS.
>> IT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE
GAMES.
>> WOW, IT'S ALMOST TIME FOR
MOVIE NIGHT.
I'M GOING TO GET SOMETHING MORE
COMFORTABLE SINCE WE'LL BE
LOUNGING AROUND.
>> SWEET.
♪♪♪
>> HEY, BRAD.
PLAYING CARDS?
>> YEAH.
>> WELL, WE SHOULD GET GOING
SOON IF WE'RE GOING TO CATCH A
MOVIE AT THE THEATER FOR MOVIE
NIGHT.
>> SAY WHAT?
>> DAVID THINKS WE'RE GOING TO
WATCH A MOVIE AT THE THEATERS.
BRIAN AND I THOUGHT WE WERE
GONNA WATCH ONE AT THE HOUSE.
THIS COULD BE DRAMA PEOPLE.
>> DAVID, CAN WE TALK?
>> UM, SURE.
>> TALK?
I NEED ANSWERS LIKE YESTERDAY.
>> IT'S ABOUT MOVIE NIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT IT?
>> IT'S JUST THAT BRIAN AND I
THOUGHT WE WOULD WATCH A MOVIE
HERE.
>> COMO SE DECE, WHAT THE HELL!
>> BUT I BOUGHT US THESE
TICKETS.
>> I DID NOT SEE THAT COMING.
>> SORRY DAVID, I DON'T KNOW.
>> I THINK I SHOULD LEAVE.
>> WAIT, DAVID --
>> I THINK GOING TO THE
MOVIES --
IS A GREAT IDEA.
THANK YOU FOR BUYING THE
TICKETS.
>> YES!
MOVIE NIGHT IS BACK ON.
>> DAVID IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
GUYS IN THE HOUSE, I CAN'T WAIT
TO GET TO KNOW HIM MORE.
>> DO YOU KNOW HOW TO PLAY
CARDS?
>> NO.
>> LET ME TEACH YOU.
>> IT'S MOVIE TIME.
>> WAIT, DAVID?
WHY ARE YOU WEARING A JACKET?
>> KEEP YOUR ARMS AND LEGS
INSIDE THE VEHICLE AT ALL TIMES,
FOLKS.
THIS COULD GET BUMPY.
>> BRIAN, I THINK WE NEED TO
TALK.
>> OKAY, LET'S BACK IT UP HERE.
IS ANYONE GOING TO TELL ME WHAT
THE HELL IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW?
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
SOMETHING HAPPENED EARLIER THAT
YOU SHOULD KNOW ABOUT.
>> WE SHOULD GET GOING SOON IF
WE'RE GOING TO CATCH A MOVIE AT
THE THEATER FOR MOVIE NIGHT.
>> I THINK GOING TO THE MOVIES
IS A GREAT IDEA.
>> WAIT, WE'RE GOING TO THE
MOVIES?
BUT I'M WEARING SHORTS.
>> AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
TALK.
>> AND WE HAVE LIFTOFF.
>> OKAY, SO, IT LOOKS LIKE THE
SPECIALS TODAY ARE DRAMA, DRAMA,
AND MORE DRAMA.
>> YOU GOT TO REMEMBER, I'M
STILL TAKING MY NAP.
>> THE REASON I WANTED TO TALK
TO YOU IS I WANTED TO KNOW --
IF YOU WOULD PUT ON SOME PANTS
AND GO TO THE THEATER WITH US.
>> YUP, THAT IS OFFICIALLY MY
LIFE.
>> THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
IS --
NO.
BECAUSE I'M FINE BEING A LITTLE
CHILLY IN THE THEATER.
♪♪♪
>>> COMING UP ON "THE HOUSE."
SONOMA: SEASON 72500,000.
>> ARE YOU BRAD CLAYTON?
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS YOUR SON.
>> SURVEY SAYS, DRAMA.
>> HI.
>> HOLY [ BLEEP ].